la pauvreté ne s'arrête pas quand la reine quand
la reine meurt la
pauvreté continue c'est comme si tout le
pays était en train de fermer
fait littéralement partie de mon français
salut je suis Marcus
donc je suis littéralement à la frontière de
comme
bootle alors que dans
cactile trois des zones les plus difficiles de Liverpool
le remarquez-vous et vous sentez-vous
que c'est dangereux ou y êtes-vous un peu
habitué
euh je suis habitué maintenant je veux dire que cette fois
c'est là que je suis descendu du train  et j'avais
peur de marcher, mais
je suppose que c'est juste
quand tu grandis quelque part que tu ne
peux pas t'y habituer, ce
qui
ne devrait pas vraiment être le cas, mais
j'ai l'impression que le gouvernement ne se soucie pas
de Liverpool
la plupart des choses là-dedans
manifestent celles qui ne
nous incluent pas
parce que vous savez que nous ne sommes pas dans une
classe moyenne ou supérieure d'anans, le Royaume
-Uni n'est
qu'une risée,
j'ai l'impression que cela représente
si parfaitement l'avant pour aimer la façon dont je '  Je l'ai décrit
trois fans de la police
dès qu'il est descendu du bus
[Musique]
Liverpool est une ville de classe, donc je
suppose qu'ils sont tous assez
euh anti-establishment et ils sont tous
assez en colère et ils sont tous
comme
euh je pense que Liverpool a une
vision complètement différente de celle de Londres
parce que
euh, nous vivons beaucoup plus comme
des vies moins privilégiées, je suppose que j'ai découvert
via Instagram que les funérailles du
couronnement coûteront
6,9 milliards de livres de différence que
la famille royale reçoit et oui d'accord
elle ne l'a pas fait ils ne sont pas nés n'ont pas demandé
à  être un
établissement royal qui entretient la famille royale
euh j'ai l'impression que cet argent est utilisé
pour les entretenir envers vous connaissez la
crise mondiale la crise nationale
j'espère qu'il n'y a pas de sans-abrisme et de personnes qui
meurent de
propriétés de pauvreté secrètes
ouais si vous sortez, il y a des sans-abri
juste là
pour
dépenser de l'argent pour des funérailles et le
couronnement de
quelqu'un comme nous n'en avons plus besoin
nous n'avons plus la monarchie
n'a rien à dire dans notre politique il n'y a
rien à d  o Je ne l'ai jamais connue c'est
qu'elle est sur nos notes et c'est tout à la
fin de la journée c'est la femme que nous
payons les gens avec mon électricité et bien pas
de 100 livres comme ça est passé de 20
livres
ouais juste le même album était comme oh
il est  un peu d'augmentation et
j'étais comme mes lumières allumées plus et
il y a des problèmes où les gens ne peuvent pas se permettre
de chauffer leurs maisons et de manger de la nourriture et
des vêtements de vélo pour les enfants, mais en
même temps, les médias ne couvrent que
la mort d'une femme pour  le dernier combien de
jours se sont écoulés depuis ouais depuis quatre
jours, nous avons eu une couverture médiatique d'une vieille
femme mourante, il avait 96 ans. c'est le monde du
football et ça
ne fera qu'empirer à moins que
quelque chose n'arrive, vous pouvez '  t Je ne
parle pas d'une révolution Je ne veux
pas de ce bruit ou de ce drame Je veux
juste pouvoir savoir que dans 10 ans
si jamais j'ai un enfant que mon enfant n'aura pas
à
vendre un [ __ ] de  membre pour chauffer une maison
avec le coût de la vie qui s'en va, vous
connaissez des
gens ha  Vivre pour travailler deux ou trois emplois en plus d'
aller à l'éducation pour
gagner de l'argent juste pour que vous puissiez vivre la
plupart des gens ne peuvent pas se permettre de manger
comme vous le savez, ces documentaires à travers
la BBC de
jeunes enfants
disant de ne pas essayer de ne pas manger beaucoup sur un
jour parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas se permettre un
quand ils vont à l'école ils n'apportent pas
le déjeuner parce que
leurs parents ne peuvent pas se le permettre ils ne peuvent pas
se payer le chauffage et
bienvenue à Liverpool
ah
bonjour princesse
non j'ai eu vraiment de la chance mon père
travaillait et ma mère travaillait,
donc mon père est chauffeur de bus et ma mère
travaillait,
elle travaillait dans des bureaux, puis elle
s'est arrêtée pour devenir soignante pour ma grand-mère
et elle est la plus gentille petite chose,
elle vient en fait de trouver un emploi maintenant à
Asda
euh oh nous  fais avec moi ouais
et ouais
toujours ouais tu as vu beaucoup de changements
depuis quand tu travailles mets-le mieux
pour le mieux
ouais pour les gourdes du point de vue de la technologie pour
les dieux mais rien n'a jamais vraiment
changé
peut-être politiquement ouais c'est c'est je peux
souviens-toi que nous étions en difficulté
dans les années 1970, j'ai dit les livres
mais vous savez que c'est différent ouais la
technologie a changé vous savez que vous avez des
caméras téléphones Internet des choses
comme ça mais bon
peut-être que la politique est comme vous le savez ça n'a jamais
vraiment été une politique différente les
politiciens n'ont jamais  vraiment été de
votre côté,
c'est presque loin,
surtout dans cette région du Royaume-Uni,
pas vraiment aimé, nous n'avons pas une bonne
réputation, ce que je trouve vraiment injuste, nous
recevons des stéréotypes, ce qui
donne que
nous sommes des gens horribles, nous faisons partie du Royaume-Uni où nous '  Je suis une sorte
d'oubliés comme si nous n'avions pas
assez d'argent, mais ouais, Dieu nous en préserve,
vous savez que la faute du gouvernement,
c'est notre faute,
c'est
dans le nord. J'ai toujours été connu comme
la classe ouvrière, donc nous sommes la classe
ouvrière de  le Royaume-Uni et nous avons toujours été
vous savez depuis le 19ème siècle cela
a toujours été
dans une classe ouvrière du Nord
mais non nous ne sommes pas vraiment je ne sais pas
si vous avez ça en France mais c'est
un peu moins  nous avons toujours eu ce
fossé
, pensez-vous que la pauvreté ici
aurait pu s'aggraver
ces dernières années,
je suppose que dans
les
climats financiers actuels, je dirais encore
plus maintenant et ça ne fera
qu'empirer vraiment, vous savez
être sur le  augmenter, vous savez que nous
avions une conversation avant sur le vol à l'
étalage,
vous savez le prix des choses maintenant, ils
ne le sont pas, ils ne doublent pas le quadruple
et donc cela va encourager beaucoup de
gens, en particulier à Liverpool, à
savoir que vous savez que les vols à l'étalage et  dans n'importe quel
cadre majeur dans n'importe quelle grande ville, vous savez
où il y a beaucoup de pauvreté, cela
va encourager plus de criminalité Je
veux vraiment que Liverpool vous sache en quelque sorte
s'attaquer au
crime
euh
s'attaquer à la pauvreté vous savez en quelque sorte
on nous donne essentiellement les miettes
Je veux Liverpool  avoir les mêmes
choses que Londres a
évidemment Liverpool n'est pas aussi grand que
Londres, mais quand vous avez un
service de transport public amélioré,
moins de crimes, vous avez plus de
groupes communautaires, je sais que je probab  Cela n'arrivera pas
de mon vivant
parce que
tout a tourné autour de Londres,
comme ne vous méprenez pas, Liverpool
rapporte de l'argent à cause des
Beatles Parce que le Liverpool Football
Club à cause du match, vous savez, mais
ce n'est pas dépensé pour les choses
que nous avons besoin
euh
[Musique]
étrangère